the gyro can experience style of music I
go anyone know how you can make that
mistake like it was the best part of the
week because by the time that happened
it was like ah [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
everything you wanna you wanna before
the fight came like they you doin the
you sided drug test then Rose was
walking back through the hallway with
her official and she crossed paths with
Jana and all by herself
and you wanna do it oh yeah she's like
in a different tone of voice to like the
weirdest like she doesn't seem like
herself first thing I mean I'm sure
she's getting in fight mode or whatever
and she's like breaking in her gloves
she's like and that give her like the
was oh you know and she gave me what's
up and then she was like um it's like
she asked me something like did you buy
the ticket her I was like it's like do
you believe him or do you believe in him
or something like that do you believe
him did you buy the ticket yeah and then
she walked off and is saying and I was
like no way and you know after the
weigh-ins like all kinds of mind [ __ ] II
[ __ ] hey yo man came back to the locker
room now we're ready all week we've been
deflecting [ __ ] we've been deflecting
[ __ ] now Rose is a very emotional person
and tempered like she's we got to keep
rolling keep rolling straight cuz she
comes in with the wrong look on her face
oh something's wrong she goes off and
does the drug test and comes back and
when she sat down she sits down and says
we have to have a meeting now that's
cold we have to have a meeting his code
for shut it down everybody get the [ __ ]
out we were bouncing we have to have a
meeting is like kind of another way of
saying start the countdown with leaving
okay we have to have a meeting and when
she said that the way she said it
I write everything came over me like oh
[ __ ] what happened and then when she
said would you honor I said in the back
what do you want to told the do you
believe him did you buy the ticket and
then left without any explanation
yo when wrote when Rose said that to me
my [ __ ] head exploded it and the only
thing I could say was oh [ __ ] I don't
want to have to [ __ ] think about this
all night
you know full-time world Muay Thai
champion and she just knows how to [ __ ]
with people brah we deflected everything
we deflected the knuckles in the mouth
in the crazy [ __ ] that she was saying
take everything and if she came and said
that when and where we got like - like
this was like she maybe she delayed our
plane good three four minutes for three
or four minutes
Trevor Tony Rose and I all sat in the
locker room just like silent because
because because that was the little that
was the little thing that could have
[ __ ] everything up because I know I
was thinking like what does that mean
she says do you believe him but you had
to know his horseshit right know what
she was doing like if you ran into
someone at the [ __ ] 7-eleven and they
said crazy [ __ ] she said it with a
calm voice no accent no accent just I
just said it real calmer like to the
point where there's there's even a
chance and I think this one there's even
the chance you wanted maybe she I don't
know man I just like roses be spooky
sometimes man like so there's a chance
that like just with the way the whole
week went that maybe that was let's say
God or a higher being or something like
that maybe that was the last test
do you [ __ ] believe him did you buy
the ticket and then just walked off was
that was a test of whether or not
alright are we gonna get all the way
down to right here and you're gonna be
[ __ ] in here now this is after the
fact system by the way like in a moment
something inside of me I was like I
don't know what she's talking about but
just give her the thumbs that like yeah
my guy believed in them like
[Applause]
yeah we were in the locker room and
really Rose had to get up to go and do
something over there when she got over
there I turned the Trevor and Tony say
hey y'all we and some oh [ __ ] little
silly things she was just trying to [ __ ]
with your head actually works got about
three minutes we would someone's unrest
amazing this [ __ ] like that works a
little mindfuck yeah what ticket I mean
cuz it's like my believin
yeah she's a wizard yeah hey well she
came back and said this [ __ ] I said this
start thinking like what did I do
now do you think it all about you don't
think it all about doing that back to
her I mean you just [ __ ] her up in the
first round so what do you say that I
think I did it like I did [ __ ] her up in
the head though you definitely did you
[ __ ] me up
she's got this thousand-yard stare she's
in and I was like what were you saying
you like I was saying the Lord I was
like oh Jesus Christ
right it was like the devil and a priest
I was like to to you together was like
she was like saying she was the boogie
was one of my favorites tear downs and
Duncan's us to build up what you handled
it was very interesting because most
people handled it they'd get in her face
- [ __ ] you [ __ ] in the real now she
willing Claudia and her would get
together and I think that emotional like
the conflict and all the extra energy
that's involved in that like he it [ __ ]
with people's heads and that's what
she's looking for I think over you Ana's
career she came in as the silent killer
who was destroying everybody and then
she found out that if I start talking
[ __ ] to someone they get [ __ ] in the
head before the fight even happens and
then it worked and it worked and it
worked so I got to the point where she's
that that that almost that that that one
weapon right there almost replaced some
of the ferociousness and in her fighting
maybe yeah like like knowing that and
that was also why the game plan was was
to go seoeon uh no matter what happens
like we know that she needs a reaction
she's looking for something nope
no videos no social media no interviews
no nothing and when she says something
don't even look at it just like she
doesn't exist just ghost it goes to the
entire times we know for a fact that
even before we were signed up to fight
she's thinking about me you know like
she knew I was on the radar
of coure a long time yeah
[Applause]